you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
russia's influence on the uk gas supply
how the potential invasion of ukraine
could be putting the west's energy
security at risk
net zero goals could cost the world more
than nine trillion dollars annually
according to a new study
and china attempts to tackle pollution
ahead of the beijing winter olympics
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
there are concerns today that any
invasion of ukraine by russia
could impact gas supplies and energy
prices the united states says it's now
in talks with major energy producing
countries about securing a supply to
europe in the event of russian troops
crossing the border well the prime
minister boris johnson said that western
economies already suffering from high
gas prices must be protected but it's
raised questions about energy security
in the west and a reliance on gas over
renewable sources
skies business correspondent paul kelso
reports
while nato countries threaten sanctions
against russia moscow's trump card in
any economic conflict will be natural
gas russia supplies 35
of europe's gas and currently much of it
comes via pipelines that cross ukraine
earning kiev valuable carriage fees now
russia is desperate to start using a new
pipeline the nord stream two it goes
under the baltic direct to germany it's
awaiting regulatory approval in berlin
but already ukraine has accused the
germans of betrayal now restricting gas
supplies would put further pressure on
european consumers this chart shows how
gas prices have risen you can see that
huge spike last year that has sent
consumer prices soaring and these prices
are likely to stay high the uk is less
directly exposed to russian gas than its
neighbors 47 of our supply still comes
from the north sea and around 30 from
european pipelines mainly from norway
holland and belgium just five percent
ultimately comes from russia the balance
22
is liquid natural gas that is imported
largely from qatar now that might be
reassuring but it doesn't mean conflict
in ukraine will not have an impact the
imf has warned that war would force
energy prices higher and inflation will
follow in global markets no one is
insulated from a revival of cold war
tensions
so let's take a look at where britain is
getting its electricity from right now
and you can see here on our data
dashboard that 53 is coming from gas and
16.6
from renewables like wind and solar
now yesterday in an interview for the
daily climate show the cop president
alok sharma said the solution to
increasing energy security for the uk is
clean energy
it takes a number of years before you
can get a
gas field operational
what i'm saying is that what we need to
be doing is more of what we have been
doing which is building for water and
renewables and obviously uh investing in
nuclear as we're doing i think that is
the answer ultimately to all of this and
actually if you if you have a look at uh
you know what uh international uh um
renowned people are saying people like
fatty bureau who runs the iea he's made
the case very clearly that uh the answer
uh to
you know the the energy uh price issues
that we have right now is to continue
to focus on net zero to continue to
focus on renewables and that's what the
government is doing
and we'll be discussing whether we can
improve our energy security using
renewables with research director of
futures chatham house bernice lee and
climate scientist michael mann that's a
little bit later
now according to the un more than 100
countries aim to reach net zero by 2050
but new research out today suggests that
could cost the world 3 trillion u.s
dollars each year more than previously
predicted the analysis by mckinsey and
co says that 9.2 trillion dollars will
need to be spent every year to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
now that's an annual increase of 3.5
trillion dollars on current spending and
around 40 increase on current investment
levels equivalent to half of global
corporate profits well our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter joins
us now at nine trillion dollars a year
hannah it sounds like a huge amount of
money
it is frankly and it is often the case
with all things climate change that
estimates and projections uh constantly
being revised upwards and that is
especially the case with cash because so
much is un unknown you know what could
possibly be costing or 9.2 trillion us
dollars a year up to 2050 you ask well
according to the mckinsey report nothing
short of a whole
sale
uh
translation transition of our entire
world the electrification of our world
changes in the way we transport
ourselves changes in manufacturing
agriculture changes in finance and
supply chains in in power gen generation
the list
goes on and on and the mckinsey report
warns as other agencies have as well
including in the uk which is struggling
with its own cost of getting to net zero
that a lot of these costs are going to
have to be front loaded or happen in the
next uh 10 to 15 years and there may
even
be some short-term impact on things like
electricity prices because of the scale
of the investment needed in the power
sector even going up for ordinary
consumers and that there will be a
particular kind of severe impact when it
comes to finding all this cash for those
developing economies like russia and
india that are still
don't have mature economies and are
still very much dependent on fossil fuel
industries to one extent or another that
plays very much into that ongoing now
about cash and justice and the
importance
of rich nations giving to poorer nations
to help them with
the transition
but if all of that sort of made your
head spin there's quite a lot of hope to
be had in the mckinsey report as well
that if all of these things happen if
this orderly economic transition happens
if there's kind of big global agreement
and national execution if government set
the right signals to markets and markets
then respond to those signals
then there could be huge savings as a
result of this huge investment we will
all live cleaner and greener lives and
of course the cost of acting now will
come in far under the cost of doing
nothing
hannah thanks very much indeed
now some of the days other climate news
now and shipping group mask will install
hundreds of offshore charging stations
around the world in a bid to cut carbon
emissions shipping vessels use fossil
fuels to generate power while waiting at
ports but these charging stations will
allow them to be powered with
electricity instead the charges will be
installed at 100 ports by 2028 cutting
emissions by 5 million tonnes every year
renewable energy developer amp energy
has announced that two of the largest
grid connected battery storage
facilities in europe will be built in
scotland due to open in april 2024 the
battery facilities will provide 800
megawatts per hour of energy storage
capacity
is expected to report record revenue
this week as consumers await the launch
of the cyber truck and cheaper electric
cars the company will open two new
factories in texas and berlin with the
hopes of doubling production capacity in
order to meet consumer demands the news
of tesla's success comes as lamborghini
announces plans to roll out its first
fully electric car by 2030
and climate change is forcing the ski
industry to spend millions of pounds on
artificial snow
drought and rising temperatures have
caused snowpack in the western united
states to decrease by 20 percent over
the last century eighty percent of the
water used in snow making will return to
the watershed when the snow melts in the
spring
well with just over two weeks ago until
the start of the winter olympics in
beijing the chinese government are
trying to curb air pollution in the city
with restrictions on big industry our
asia correspondent tom cheshire has more
it can change relatively quickly here
today is an okay day for pollution but
the last few days have been pretty
miserable with levels
well above what the beijing runners
clubs here consider safe to exercise in
so that's what athletes may well be
facing because officials have warned of
these very unfavorable weather
conditions now what usually happens here
ahead of a big event like a political
parade or an international summit is
that businesses are told to shut down to
try and clear the sky so you get what's
called the beijing blue uh on your
television screens and officials will be
trying some of that they said if it
doesn't look like it's going to be good
they will ask some of the smaller
businesses around here to stop operating
they also said they're not going to ask
bigger businesses crucial to the economy
to stop operating even if they are
polluting in terms of energy production
and things like that because they need
to get the economy going to keep it on
track i think that shows really
encapsulate what beijing has been doing
over the last few years it has made
tremendous progress in getting the
levels of smog down from the days of
what was called the airpocalypse you get
fewer and fewer of those every day and
they've done that by relocating a lot of
industry by planting trees and other
sorts of measures at the same time
although they've hit their targets that
they've set those targets are several
times more dangerous than what the world
health organization recommends so there
is this lingering question of how far
beijing is really prepared to go to
eliminate this problem completely and
whether it's prepared to sacrifice any
economic security any development growth
as a result of that i think what is
looking very probable is that any
athletes coming here to compete in the
games in not very many days time now
they are going to get a beijing lungful
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
research director of futures at chatham
house bernice lee and climate scientist
michael mann we're going to be
discussing energy security and tackling
the cost of net zero
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
research director of futures at chatham
house bernice lee and climate scientist
michael mann say good evening to you too
lovely to see you both
so global gas prices are high and might
go much higher if the current tension
between russia and ukraine escalates as
we heard earlier in the show russia to a
certain extent controls the world's
energy security so bernice to you
explain to us what energy security risks
does russia pose to the u.s and to other
western countries as well
well as we heard as well earlier from
shaman
that indeed the international energy
agency has been warning us that russia
is manipulating supplies in a
geopolitical power play and that does
mean that we will be vulnerable if we
were dependent on heavily on russian
supplies it also underlines the fact
that gas is inherently volatile and
unreliable as a source of energy really
and we have a risk of disruption in many
ways and very vulnerable to the worms of
the industry at the same time so
therefore it is quite quite important
that we're investing in energy security
in much more comprehensive way beyond
just fossil fuel security which will of
course mean
investing more in renewable energy in
diversification and obviously most
importantly as well energy efficiencies
are they were using less in the first
place
and in the case of any kind of invasion
if that were to happen at michael mann
even those countries that rely less on
russian exports could be hit by a global
rise in prices presumably
yeah and you know this is a reminder of
uh one of the hidden costs of our
addiction to fossil fuels of our
continued reliance on fossil fuels
it
puts us at risk um
when it comes to the instability of
energy markets uh when we rely on
foreign sources sources of oil natural
gas um it really underscores the
importance of energy independence and
that can be achieved of course through
renewable energy
wind solar geothermal that can all be
manufactured domestically and then we
don't have to rely upon access to
pipelines um
foreign sources of fossil fuels and we
also don't end up having to fight many
of these extremely expensive uh and
deadly wars that have been fought over
the years
over access to fossil fuel resources
so bernice do you agree with that that
in the future that's the only way to go
because a lot of people will say you
can't rely just on renewable energy
because then you need the wind to blow
and the sun to shine for example and
that can't be relied on
here's one that as michael just
mentioned we need a variety of sources
not just one at the same time it's also
very important to remind ourselves that
actually managing our demand using less
is actually a very important starting
point as well we have already heard that
i think it was hard and brief the
website was talking about that energy
bills in the uk is about two and a half
billion
pounds higher than they would have been
if we actually had not scrapped our
climate policies so it's just quite
clear that you know diversification when
investing in more renewables cleaner
energy actually saves money as well as
increases security as well in the medium
and long term
so michael what action should be taken
now to protect countries in this in this
current crisis what would you recommend
well yeah i agree with everything that
bernice just said there and um again you
know we do face this sort of
short-term
shortfall of of energy in part because
of the economic rebound from the
pandemic and so we have to recognize
that there are some short-term
challenges that we face and not lose
sight of the longer-term challenge
because in the end regardless of what
happens to oil prices and and uh fossil
fuel energy prices right now
in the end uh it will be far cheaper for
us to move in the direction of renewable
energy
it's better for the economy it's better
for the planet and so we have to
continue to decarbonize our economy we
have to continue to work towards global
negotiations to reduce carbon emissions
dramatically over the next decade or so
and that means no new fossil fuel
infrastructure even the conservative iea
has said that if we are to stabilize
warming below truly catastrophic levels
of more than one and a half degrees
celsius
we cannot invest in any new fossil fuel
infrastructure any new pipelines oil
natural gas pipelines coal mines and so
we have to keep that in mind even as we
deal with the immediate challenges that
we face okay let's move on to our next
topic shall we because
9.2 trillion dollars a year that's how
much the world needs to spend every year
in order to reach net zero and maintain
a habitable world according to new
analysis by mckinsey consultancy it
sounds like a lot but it is and if you
consider climate change to be is it
really that much if you consider climate
change to be an existential crisis now
if you've seen the film don't look up
you'll know that one of the points it
makes is that an obsession with money
ultimately well no spoilers but it
doesn't end well for them so bernice a
fundamental transformation of the world
economy and nine trillion dollars should
be spent annually in investment i mean
it's it's a huge amount it's a big ask
is it pie in the sky will it happen do
you think
it is a huge ask but at the same time i
think mckenzie has pointed out that
actually the cost of doing nothing would
be much much higher and so in some sense
it is in the context of much larger cost
of the economy and i think all the
studies we've looked at we're talking
about 10 23
you know the color cost of impacts and
that actually means that it will be cost
something a lot more than what covert is
currently costing us for example and
also i think the good news as well or
the hope at least is that because
historically all these modeling has
always underestimated how quickly
renewables have gotten cheaper in the
past so there is great hope that
actually we will get a lot cheaper and
therefore the cost is less than what
this estimate would say so on the one
side impacts cost far more
on the other side actually hopefully if
the numbers are you know if the cost of
the fast cost of reduction is
underestimated on the other side there
is a great chance that actually we will
come on inside a lot more balanced than
these numbers necessarily imply
michael do you agree with that analysis
and ultimately who's going to be
responsible for this transformation and
this investment are we talking about
governments are we talking about
corporations
well it's all of the above right we have
to work together um the the investment
uh world uh uh governments um
individuals uh it's all hands on deck
and i would uh absolutely uh reiterate
the central points that bernice just
made first of all when it comes to the
cost of action
this report i haven't looked at it in
detail yet but it probably relies for
example on the iea projections of
renewable energy costs and the iea has
dramatically
underestimated
the um the the lowering in uh cost of
renewable energy in past years uh over
the past decade they have consistently
therefore overestimated the cost of the
transition to renewable energy and if
this report for example uses those
numbers and i suspect it does then it is
overestimating how much it will cost
to decarbonize our economy
at the same time
there are all of these hidden costs that
aren't entirely taken into account in
many of these sorts of estimates uh the
hidden cost of our reliance on fossil
fuels we already talked about the uh
national security
challenges that we face um the the
the cost of maintaining a military to
fight battles um in foreign lands to
maintain access to fossil fuels and the
health cost and and you know there was a
segment earlier in the program about
beijing and and the health um you know
the health challenges that they are
facing because of their continued
reliance on dirty energy and so when we
take all those into account i suspect
the cost of inaction
is even greater than implied in the
mckinsey report but as bernice said even
given mckinsey's very conservative
numbers it's very clear that the cost of
inaction is far greater than the cost of
taking action and that's all the more
reason to accelerate our efforts
domestically
here in the united states in europe and
our efforts diplomatically uh when we
return to the table uh next year in the
one year follow-up to the glasgow
conference there's an opportunity to
really ratchet up those commitments and
bernice then briefly how do you
communicate the message either
internationally and diplomatically but
also to consumers as well that the money
needs to be spent
look i mean it will cost a lot more if
we don't spend it now a lot of it is fun
loaded there's also you know as we are
now increasingly realizing the cost of
the impacts are coming through earlier
than we think and therefore it is quite
important that we invest now and the
action time is really now rather than
later
okay well bernice lee and michael mann
always interesting to get your thoughts
thanks so much for for joining us
tonight
and just let you know that tomorrow i'll
be joined by the director and founder of
uplift tessa khan and policy director at
the grantham ins research institute on
climate change and the environment bob
ward but for now thanks for watching
i'll see you next time
[Music]